Oh
here she come
[Music]
I want one this horror this hard I want
this Jo this hard it's a foolproof motor
it's Kubota diesel 44 horsepower iron 18
foot-pounds of torque for every hour run
time you know unburnable three quarters
of a gallon so you can go for days on
fuel you register as a boat is
completely a harm center fibia its
exhaust filled tires
we're deflating the tires see them
getting low right now that's right there
we'll drop it about a foot if you got
some money and some territory to play
with this hard this is definitely the
ultimate fired up for them
very loud
why where did this idea come from well
start out in Russia Siberia guys are
adamant Fisher's hunters they won't go
out but at the same time temperatures
are cold they're minus 58 degrees like
that is cold and it's extreme conditions
that they're going could pack a ton of
gear back here those fold down and make
a hammock so you can sleep two guys here
actually I'm fixing to put tunes on this
one you are yep you got to do my bike
the sky's limit what do you want to do
with one of these machines so we'll just
start over
yeah hazard lights windshield wiper
washer heater auxilary engine fan horn
turn signals backup camera ready to rope
so you familiar with this trail now
no problem out of you no problem
[Music]
Sunday Drive
this ain't good man
to go in this
that's a quick shirt pride house I
speechless